we're being trying to be extra careful
on sound this time we had a little
problem sport i think representative
mcguire is just suggesting we might be
able to use it to pick
to spread it more evenly in front of the
all right terrific um before we begin um
i'm
going to ask uh representative mcdonald
to take attendance and uh this committee
doesn't meet very frequently and we
haven't met recently so this is also a
way for us to all say good morning to
each other by remembering who we are
mcdonald if you could take the roll call
for attendance thank you madam chairman
uh representative shortly for
representative griffin
here
representative kennedy for
representative lynn
representative mcdonald is here
representative mcguire
representative o'hara
marjorie smith
representative stephen smith yeah
representative border for representative
weber
thank you very much for doing that um
the first uh item that is
going to be mentioned is that since we
met the census data has been released i
think when we met we anticipated it was
going to be released on a monday it was
actually released the thursday before
that information has been
put on the new hampshire
website the new hampshire government
website if you go to the
committee on redistricting site through
the house of representatives there is a
icon for census data if you click on
that it takes you to another length
nothing is simple no matter what they
tell you and you click on that and that
will take you to the osi government red
page which has the census data that
census data there is compiled with
county numbers and community numbers and
we're going to talk a little bit later
about those numbers
but if you can if you're interested in
seeing those numbers that's where you
should go to see them if you try to do
it through the census webpage quite
frankly it's an exercise in frustration
and when they have multiple videos to
tell you how to use their own web page
you know you're in trouble so i would
suggest that you go to the website
through our
website at the location through our
website to take a look at it um in
regards to the the numbers that are on
there committee members have been
provided with uh this morning
and an email sent late last night i
apologize to committee members uh the
county population data that has been
released
this is important for this committee
because our work is really focused on
the county breakout of population
and
it shows this is to allocate the number
of representatives
of 400 per population
which works out to 3
43.8225
as to persons per rep
and i expect that we're going to have
some discussion on grounding because
this is actually a math exercise
and
you're going to see i think when we go
through data that the math matters
so what you have in front of you is the
2020 county population which works out
to our state total of 1
and as a percentage of the state
population
not a surprise hillsborough is the
largest
and the smallest for population is
co-ops
there is also a column on the county
as to that that the committee is looking
at as to what would be the perfect
persons per rep and what that would work
out to be
then there is a rounded number on the
committee
worksheet
and
that totals the 400 representatives
which works out to an allocation for
example of hillsborough of 123
and
coast again the lowest county of nine
reps
and just for a minute representative um
ross he was you were sort of uh
rounding work
can you take a quick look at this and
tell me sort of how many decimal points
i press the button yeah yeah um is that
better yes
so it's taken out on the sheet it's
taken out to 10 decimal points and it
uses a strict rounding so um point you
know 1.49 is not two 1.49 is one
um so it's it's i took it out to the
point where it was insignificant for the
purposes of rounding um actually it's
well beyond that i think i only need to
go out um i think four or five in some
cases
but it's it's to show all the math so
it's as transparent as possible
and the last column on the sheet that
we're reviewing compares the
rounded allocation to what is currently
the location and again this is math and
for purposes of discussion
later um it shows that
cheshire koas and grafton
would be losing a rep under the current
allocation and hillsborough rockingham
and stratford would be gaining a wrap
and that is somewhat consistent with
what you've heard
publicly in articles that i've seen
published is that the population seems
to have shifted south and to the east
so
those numbers are available on
support
yep representative smith
i wish my grandson was here because he
let me skip and i'll come back when i
have the question more organized all
right we're going to come back to this
later i wanted to lay this out because
of course the foundation for anything we
do is numbers
um and anything we do has to do with
maps
and
we have with us this morning is we have
with us this morning joel anderson
joel anderson is a former 30 some odd
year employee
he retired earlier this year thank you
for joining us joe joel
worked with the house 10 years ago when
developing the software that was used
for the mapping program
and
joel came in
last month
to do a demonstration
um here as to the software as to how it
would work
and the decision has been made for for
us to proceed with using this software
which allows us to deal with the
floatarial issue that's provided for in
our constitution and that we need to do
it uses the method the same method of
math as a component method as compared
to another method that had been used
a couple of decades ago and can't be
used anymore
and i want to thank joel for
agreeing to come back as a part-time
employee of
supposed to be part-time i don't know
that it's been part-time the last few
days
of the general court and
he is here to give us a demonstration
and we are also going to talk about
these thumb drives that you all have at
the end of the presentation so welcome
joel
uh glad to be here um
and um
looking forward to serving the the
committee
and helping them with this
this
mapping tool that you could use to draw
maps
but you can use the
question
oh okay
i'm not sure it's there for
amplification do you have the red button
impressed
yeah i do and if it becomes a problem
um
okay there we go let's get it out of
track
um
so um
you you've already heard a little
history let me interrupt you i'm gonna
request that the doors not be blocked
there's plenty of room on the other side
of the room for people to stand if they
want to take pictures um there is a
tripod with the camera set up in in
front of one half of the door so i'm
going to ask the gentleman in front of
the other half to please move i want the
entrances to the room uh kept open thank
you
sorry for the interruption no problem no
problem um
so the just a quick history on on this
software it's um it was developed by me
10 years ago because we didn't have any
software at the time
to do our mapping
there weren't any commercial products
available that new hampshire could use
because of the fact that we have
materials and that's a rare thing
maybe not used by any other state i
think there may be a few localities that
use it now and then but
anyway um in terms of commercial
software wasn't available so i um i
decided i thought that i might be able
to uh develop some
some software that could do it for us
and um so i did some preliminary work on
it looked like it would work and um so i
went and went
ahead and developed the whole thing
um i'm not a professional programmer
just so you all know i just kind of
picked it up on myself on my own
and uh so
i do well enough but there's a lot of
technicalities that i may not be
that knowledgeable about
um
so
why don't we go ahead
and
start up the software
so that you can see it
i should be
looks like the post disabled participant
okay
okay well let's see it
can't share my screen right now via zoom
so i can just do you want me to just go
oh
great question so
every everybody hates fliterials but
they're a mathematical necessity to
comply with the federal one-man one-vote
rule where we have to have districts as
close to perfect population as we can
get
but new hampshire being unique that we
have so many little pieces to put
together and we can't cross county lines
it isn't always possible to put towns
together for multi-seat districts that
are perfect so the overage goes into the
materials there's just no other way to
do it here to get it all to work out so
you um
a couple of things about the software in
the meantime um
uh when is there there's some discussion
i think
both of you were speaking about the uh
both of you were speaking about the
number of um
of what the ideal population is for
representatives
that number of
343.8 something something whatever
so just so you know that the the
software uses that fractional number so
it uses the exact amount it doesn't do
any rounding in it
so um
in terms of doing all the computations
so that makes a minor difference you
know when you when you do the
computations if instead of using a whole
number
and the reason for that is is basically
um
statistics
generally
in statistics generally it's i think
it's good you're going to do any
rounding to do the rounding at the end
of all your
computations rather than do some kind of
rounding in the middle of your
computations so
so that's where the the software works
it uses the exact number for ideal
population
uh the software also
um in terms of
what's
considered contiguous
um and that's a requirement of the
constitution you're going to put two
talents together they have to be
contiguous for purposes of this software
and it can be changed but the way it's
set up is that
uh two towns that come together at a
point
are considered contiguous
and um
last year's um map
they are the current redistricting we
use that in one place in stratford
county there are two towns that come
together at a point and they were made
things to keep in mind that can be
oh so
so it's is it it's working now okay i
don't have to do anything sorry
while joe's clicking i'm reminded that
the live stream needs us to be pressing
the button and to be closer to the mic
when we speak so
help
so uh
so this is when you start up the
software and i should say this soft
what you're seeing here
we're supposedly being good with
ah there we go
excellent
okay um first off i just want to say
that what you're seeing here is
basically
the um
the setup that
the the
software as it looked 10 years ago
and um
when you uh
there's just a mine a couple of minor
changes
the the software that that you have
um that you'll be loading on
will look just a slightly different than
this in terms of the the buttons at the
very top
and uh
and just other just minor changes but
for the most part when you load it up
it's going to look like this
um okay so this is the when you when you
start up the software the first thing
you get is a cover page and um
you'll see it says house redistricting
so it says house redistricting you can
type in this area whatever you would
like to it's your plan
so you could you know if you want to put
any notes or whatever concerning your
plan you can type it in here and it will
be saved
um
so there's a series of tabs
going along i don't know if you can see
my cursor well enough but there's a
series of tabs for all the county names
so if i um
i'm going to go just to
sullivan county
and so it this brings up the
the map of sullivan
and
um
i'm just going to go through
with you know how you you go about
making a
um
district how you do a map i'm just going
to take a look at claremont down here
claremont you see has three different
wards
they're all about the same same size
and the
for back in 2010 the ideal population
was um
3291 and so you can see each one of
these wards is is large enough to have
its own seat
so we we can go ahead and
start creating districts um
by you by clicking on the label and say
create a district so this software is
all basically label based
in terms of how you operate so you click
on a label you're given options as to
what you can do at that point sometimes
it restricts what you can do
because um
decide that i want to put playing field
with
claremont because they're not contiguous
so like it won't allow you to put you
know non-contiguous towns together into
the district so it has certain rules
like that
so here we um we have
ward 3 that we put into a district the
label here it's probably pretty small i
don't know if you can see it or not but
it says um it's labeled as district one
it has one seat
it tells you what the population of
of the town is and i should have said
that earlier on all of these labels
these town labels tell you what the
and um
so
so you so you're given this information
from the label this is now a district
label
it's it's ordered in uh
gold
so that means it's a district label
it's uh colored in claremont um
ward three you know in blue so you know
that's a district
um and then also down below it'll it'll
show you
uh two other numbers it says um
says uh you know the overall population
of ward three is 4260
this numbered below at 976
means those are the the
um that if you took 4 267 and subtracted
off the ideal population
of 3291 you would get this number 976.
that basically tells you that's how many
more
uh that's how many people aren't really
being represented
in that board so you need to add
they this this district needs more
representation basically one seat
doesn't do this okay you gotta get more
um so and then after that you'll get a
uh
percent deviation
29.6
and what that's the the the deviation
that you're going to be working with
that's the primary number that you're
always going to look at and see whether
or not it's a deviation that's
acceptable
in the past
um
we've used plus or minus five percent
basically
the court's my understanding is that
that's if that's a an acceptable
uh deviation to stay within if you go
outside of that then you're going to
have to answer why you went outside of
that
to the courts
so
so you can um
so basically you're trying to stay plus
or minus 5
so we're at 29.6
right now so we're gonna have to do
something else with with ward 3.
i'm going to go ahead and work with the
other wards
and um in claremont you'll see that they
they all have similar populations
claremont we did their ward line so that
they would their wards would be
basically of the same population that's
what cities generally do
um you know after the census numbers
come out so we're expecting that many
cities will be
redrawing word lines in the next few
months
so
excuse me um
so i'm going to turn ward one
into a district you can see i have an
option i can create a district or i
could join ward one with world war three
to one district
but i'm not doing that i'm just creating
another district
you'll see similar numbers here for ward
one because its population is similar to
ward three
um i'm gonna make ward two into a
district so now we have three districts
in claremont
they all are in need of more
representation in new hampshire we have
flow tarials to take care of that
so i'm going to
we'll just make
form them into one material you know
floaterial is just
you're probably familiar with this
material it's just composed of of
underlying
uh regulator districts that are all
combined together and this of floater is
kind of an overlay district
so
we'll make a floaterial here
so i can create a float now a floaterial
this this this black label here
is the
material label
it's given a district number it has one
seat
um and then it has a number here that
gives you the
um
the total population of the flow now and
actually it's its population
right now is the same as war three so
it's what it will do is total up the
total population within the flow terial
that's what that number will tell you
the number below that you don't need to
worry about that one too much it's just
kind of a it's a number you can
kind of look at to see well
districts can i put in
that will fit within the floater by
in terms of how much how much more
population those other districts need so
they got 2 315 more
extra
populations population folks that could
go into that district so
um i'm going to take ward one and join
that in with with the new floaterial
so i have an option of joining the float
that's what i'm going to do join the
float
this software just so you know if you
try and go ahead and
say create another district someplace up
here like a cornish it won't let you do
that because floaterials always have to
have more than one member
district underlying it so it's going to
say next thing you have to do is you
have to add a district to the floater
so i'm adding board one
i'm gonna join that
and i'm gonna join in ward two gonna
join that float
okay
the um
then you can rearrange these labels
however you want to move them around
wherever you need to move them you know
sometimes they get on top of each other
so you can just move them so you can see
things as well
so now what you'll see is that the
if you look at the deviations
for
that show
they they're going to show only in the
regular districts you don't get a
deviation for the entire floateral you
get it for each one of the separate
districts that's kind of part of the
component method
is that's that's where the the uh
that's the level at which the deviations
are calculated
basically that that one seed in the flow
material has been divided out amongst
the three underlying districts based
upon the population of each one of those
districts
so
and now you'll see that you look at the
deviation of
one two and three they're all
uh within that that five percent some
two of them are above it or two and ward
one
and ward three is um just below negative
one point seven percent so basically if
you see a if you see a deviation that
that's over
um
the uh over zero it's a positive number
number that means basically
you're you're you
you uh it could actually use a few more
um a little bit more representation
but um it's sort of hard to give just a
little bit more you know once you get
that close especially with it within a
reasonable deviation so that's where you
stop
um i award like word three that's a
negative number that means it got a
little bit
more representation than it needed but
that's okay because it's within that
five percent
so there you go that's basically um
how you go about making
districts and materials and and what i
can do
i could just also
um
fill in the rest what i'm planning on
doing is is filling in the the rest of
sullivan county um
with actually what the present map is
for sullivan county
so you can just see how
different districts can go together in
different sizes and number and how they
can go together and flow
thank you for taking my question here so
again in my ignorance
claremont is a city and has rewards are
we required to acknowledge those wards
when we redistrict
one
two if there weren't enough people
would we be able to pull people from a
surrounding town
to make up the number
yeah in terms of the and one last thing
about getting a message from someone
who's watching on youtube and they
cannot hear on youtube
they cannot see an app
showing this on youtube was not uh did
not make it on the list of priorities so
i'm not sure that it
is occurring
um we wanted to make sure the committee
and that it was
here and again i'm asking everybody to
try and
speak a little louder
i don't know that you can pull the
microphone any closer than it is so
oh
uh so in terms of the question so the
question is as to recognition of wards
if you want to take that and the ability
to add
okay
yeah so in terms of um yeah i mean the
the uh
the awards of a city
are are recognized you know when it
i think pretty much you if a city has
words then
um i think there's an obligation if
they're true true
of the city then there's an obligation
to recognize them they are recognized in
the software
um there's though though doesn't mean
that
you can't lump them all together
that happened in lebanon last time
around
all three wards were put together into
one ward
i mean into into one district and and
that was due partly because of the
just the uh difficulty they're down in
the corner of the county they had kind
of strange uh population numbers for
their awards and they kind of had to be
all put together
um it's it's also possible to yeah
wards under the software
um and and just in redistricting in
general
um there's nothing that limits them in
terms of what they can be combined with
so that you can certainly combine them
with with towns outside and that
happened with uh conquer i think
hopkinton and ward something else
were put into a district of its own
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
joel for the presentation
uh i have two quick questions um i
assume that the database is loaded with
the census data after the cities have
done their redistricting there will be
new population numbers for the wards can
those new population numbers then be
added to your database to replace the
census numbers
yeah
and the second question if i may
uh joel you mentioned that the software
tries to ensure that when you're
creating floaterials that the
territories are contiguous
some years ago
there was a floaterial created that
included the town of merrimack and the
town of litchfield
which geographically is contiguous but
there's no way from the people in
merrimack to get to litchfield
because there's no bridge in the
merrimack river separates the two
does your software take into
consideration those natural boundaries
or barriers uh when looking at adjoining
communities to see if they're truly
contiguous
truly contiguous would be a matter of
definition i think joel um i believe it
does not is that correct
that's right um in terms of highways or
bodies of water that type of thing
that's standard for the government in
this required federal standard as to
population and representation
so thank you
thank
you okay so you want to do a couple more
in sullivan county sullivan county sure
so here's um gonna go to charlestown
and um so it's got a population of five
thousand one hundred and fourteen so we
can use a seat so we're gonna give it a
seat and then then you'll see all these
um some smaller towns down in the the
southern tier
and none of them can can
have a seat of their own so they're
going to need to be combined together in
order to
have a sufficient population to to
deserve at least one seat
so i'm going to create another
district of langdon and backworth we're
going to join in you'll see when you
when you can join into a district you're
sometimes given an option as to which
district you want to go into if the town
is next to two districts
so back with is next to charlestown and
also langdon so you get a choice but by
color
so we're gonna go we're gonna stay with
yellow here
i'm gonna keep going with yellow and
just keep combining these together
um let's say here you're at a point
where um
we're we're up to a point where
we've gone over the total population
this district is is above the ideal
population so we could stop here and say
okay we got it big enough okay but then
we're going to say well actually though
these th is not within plus or minus
five percent so so how are we going to
settle that well you form a flow
material if you can't of course and so
we could say well let's see let's try
to put uh the blue district together
with the yellow district so that's
charlestown so we could create a float
there
and then we're going to join in this
other new district to that
and um so and we can then it shows you
what the the resulting deviations are
well it if you look at the charlestown
number it's negative one point
negative one percent deviation so that's
fine if you look at the the yellow
district
uh it's the deviation is negative 18.1
not so good so that that didn't work
okay
so one way to fix that would be you can
see that there's there's a little bit
the yellow district has
um is a little over represented so if we
put some more people into that that
yellow district perhaps the float work
so what i'm going to do is just add i'm
going to delete this flow terial for now
and i'm going to add in
um goshen
to increase the population a little bit
um and so
now it's a higher population and so now
um
the deviation works out at this point
two percent two percent for the uh the
blue region or the purplish region
and uh negative four percent for the
yellow so it succeeded that's good
so it's a good thing because this is
what the map was last time around so you
know if it didn't work out we were in
big trouble here
now okay so then you go on to
you could say okay um
we can make newport into a district
and then unity well unity has to go in
with with something
okay
so um we would put unity
um it all these other districts are
already filled up they're already
already made into a float the numbers
work so unity can't go in with any of
the areas in the float uh district so
it's going to have to be put into
newport okay that's the sort of the only
option under this plan
um it might be a little some might say
that's a little unfortunate because
newport has is given two seats here and
its deviation is negative one percent
which is great it would be perfect just
to give newport two seats
but the problem is unity has to go
somewhere
okay so the only option is
okay so we added it in but the deviation
now is 24.4
so then
so the the
trick now
is to try to come up with a
um
you know something so put together some
other regular districts that we can
combine in with this newly created
district so that our deviations work out
so as you can see this is kind of tricky
sort of stuff
a little bit you have to think about it
some people get good at it i never did
it very much myself mainly i just kind
of developed the tool and let other
so i'm going to put
sunapee
sunny baby would be great to leave by
itself too
it takes one seat just fine but the
problem is to make the numbers work
overall with the remaining number of
limited number of talents to add to it
um it just turns out it's going to have
to go into a
into a district also
into a multi-town district so i'm going
to add in
um
add in croydon to it so
and then what i'm going to do this is
going to be a little tricky if i try to
the deviation on both of them does not
work out they have a the red is negative
six percent
and the the pink is negative six percent
two so it doesn't quite work
so we got to do something else
and uh the other option
and there are ways after you look at the
numbers a little bit you would know
before doing that that that probably
wouldn't work because of the deviations
of the two underlying uh districts
they're at about 25
they would need to be both at closer to
50 in order for that to work
so um
well so uh what i'm gonna do is form uh
one more district with the remaining
okay
and so
here we have another district
um this one here actually
you can see that it's a fairly large
district of 8300 people
it it can take two seats i'm going to
see it i'm going to change give it two
seats
there you go
now you'll you'll see it's it still
needs a little bit more it's a 26
percent
uh deviation
and um i'm going to try to combine all
these districts together into a float
and see if it works and it's supposed to
work because it did before so i'm going
to create a float
i'm going to join join to it
join this one to that one
here i have an option of which float i
want to join i have to decide which one
it is it's it's a float 11.
um
so the all the all the deviations the
peak is at 3.7 the the red is at 4.5 and
the blue is at 5.0
so it's right on the edge but it makes
it
so
basically we've succeeded with sullivan
county
um and this is what
oh
yeah that will appear also
i'm sorry to think that joel could you
explain what's on the left side of the
screen as i'm looking at it and will
that appear on the thumb drive when
we're using
this program right
uh yeah this this will be part of what
you'll have appear on the left hand side
so this is just a tabulation of all of
which you see on the right inside of the
you know the map part which is putting
it in a
tabular form and so these are all the
so look at
the
the top area
it shows uh ward three
it's district one has one seat and it
shows what its deviation is negative 1.7
um and then it does the same for
uh ward one and ward two they're all
separate districts and then below that
you'll see word one two and three
all on top of each other and then it's
it has a district number of a four
put in an f4 so you can kind of keep
track of what the floats are
and you'll see that there's no deviation
for the flow floats never have a
deviation
um
and so that's just a tabular form so
that's a good way
of um just
sort of keeping track
of
what you what you you've done in a
tabular format down below it'll give you
the total seats
that are are part of it 13
in sullivan and then it gives you the
the deviation range
of negative four percent to five percent
i'm wondering uh
you said that floats don't have a
deviation could you just explain why
that is
kind of the basic idea is what you want
to do in any area where people are
voting
um
is to
they're they're they're on a they're in
a particular let's say if you're you're
in a uh
in a district such as ward one and
in claremont
you have your own district your own
person you're voting for
and then you have
uh the the float person that you're
voting for also
um and so you're in a particular
situation that's different from the
person in the next ward over
okay and so what we're trying to do is
figure out whether or not a person in
each area um what what kind of their
voting strength is what their their
voting weight is
okay
if if you just
if you do it on a floaterial test basis
you would maybe have one percentage one
percent for everyone for that whole area
and that's more like now and that might
be adding all the numbers together right
between all the underlying districts
um but you
you would
you know the new hampshire supreme court
said if you if you do that type of thing
you're basically asking what the true
deviation is because everyone's not in
the same situation
you know within that whole material
everyone has its own
individual war too that they're going in
and their populations may be
i don't know if that's a good enough
explanation
that's great great explanation thank you
okay
other questions for joel representative
smith
thank you
joel this has been very very helpful
is it
in any way possible
to make things more complicated rather
than less
by taking a look at other factors in
addition
to those that you have in here now for
example
do all those towns
are they in the same
school district
or have you split up school district
representation
i think i'll answer that representative
smith the
requirement is as to numbers
um in the final analysis that that is
the the first thing that needs to be
determined so
um
just like the geography this is a math
exercise and i understand that you were
on the committee a
couple of you have some experience with
actually cranking the numbers so
this is this is an attempt to avoid the
cranking of the numbers i i think that's
sort of where we're at it's a math
exercise is that correct joel
yeah i mean that's
they're they're uh yeah there isn't any
other data in here except just for the
population numbers
i mean it so this this tool is just
designed to answer the one question
basically you know does it comply with
the one person one vote requirement of
the federal constitution
so so but those things can be
considered certainly when you're looking
at various maps
and
you know maps that that make sense and
comply with the deviation requirement
you could say well does it really make
sense to put this town together that
time there are separate school districts
there's no road between them maybe you
can consider those things at that point
and maybe
maybe that and that may be why you
choose one map over another
correct and for example you might
find that while on the map itself it
doesn't make a lot of sense but if
there's a highway
that connects some it makes sense for a
particular district
representative o'hara you have yeah i
just wanted to make a comment that the
school district thing would be a little
bit of an issue in our county because
one of our uh towns shared school
district with a different county
northfield
well
thank you and i will tell you i come
from goffstown which i have seen
um school districts
um change
as to who
is part of it certainly over the course
of of 10 years and at least as far as i
know we've managed to keep our town
boundaries somewhat
consistent um representative
ross representative barry did i see your
anybody else
representative
thank you manager i'm not sure if this
is the appropriate time to ask the
question but i'm curious what all is on
the thumb drive right okay so that's i
sort of wanted to get through the
questions says to the and joel can you
just humor my
non-technological self and tell me how
it is i move those little boxes of data
around
you just hit him with the cursor and
move them oh
um yeah just the cursor
just you you put the little pointer on
the
on the label the cursor on the label and
click
and you can move it okay
yeah you can move it moves at that point
so you can you can even you know if you
mix up your labels
and uh
you know if i had if i had a
centipede here
you know it's somehow or another i got
the label way off and i
i mixed up overs whereas this the
centerpiece label is up here
and i forget which one's sunapee you say
i can just click on the centerview label
and create a district and it'll say oh
it's it's there so it's it's always tied
to the area the label is
so other questions on the software
representative
thank you for madam chair um is this
software available to the general public
any other questions in regards to this
representative
what is the best software for us to use
to open up this manager oh we're gonna
go through how to open it up okay all
right so you all
you all have a thumb drive
and um as representative bergeron
pointed out
uh there is going to be data that
changes specifically in regards to city
boards because that would not that that
will be something we are dealing with
locally so you will be getting updates
and
it's my understanding that there were
some
there might be some technical glitches
in this data remember this data was just
released less than two weeks ago
um joel has been downloading it and try
to make sure that the programming
matches
all of the data so joel is going to go
use this on your own computer
and what if anything might not be
exactly right at the current time that
we will need updated thumb drives for
joel
okay um
and i'm sure would it be okay there were
a couple other things they wanted to
cover on that oh sure go ahead i'm sorry
go ahead okay and then i can get back to
the thumbnails
um
i just wanted to go through quickly
um that once you have a
plan put together for uh say a county
um there's there's option options at the
top
where you can save and open a county
so so you can you know save your work
so i'm going to just save the county
you know just save your plan and so i'm
and so now it's saved that that county
is saved
if i um go on to a
another county i'm just going to go
um
to merrimack
one thing that i wanted to to a couple
things i just wanted to show
here in terms of
merrimack it could be could be any
counting i'm just going to merrimack
um
that there's a function in here called
solutions
there's a there's a label
or a button that you can press called
solutions and what that is is is it
brings up there's a database behind each
one of the counties
that's pre-compiled that shows
uh various uh potential maps
uh for that county that that comply with
the the five percent you know 10 overall
deviation requirement
um and it's there's certain
there's
it's a separate program that's run ahead
of time
to create the database
and
there's certain parameters that are used
with the intent of creating uh maps that
generally
have are smaller in size
and in population
and which
um
and are more you know numerous to have
more districts rather than fewer which i
think generally people have come to
accept is is probably a
a good idea at least last time around 10
years ago that was one of the guidelines
of the committee we want to create
maps with as many districts as possible
so anyway um
so
there are these
so that's been
done um and
so i can just show that to you if i
press up solutions button for an empty
map
uh here in merrimack it's going to pop
up a table
that shows um
various potential maps
for the the county and this doesn't mean
that these are the only maps that are
possible certainly other maps might be
suitable doesn't mean that every map on
here is a good map okay but it's just an
aid a tool that members can use
to
to explore what what different maps
representative
thank you madam chair
the solutions
tab is that just map out base districts
or also floaters
protereals because that's the difficulty
you know
it's not so easy to put together maps
because of those materials
representative lane
thank you um
who developed those maps
it's a piece of software that i
developed
because
and that's that was developed
in the last during the last 10 years
since the last
time this was done
and i just i just saw that you know
there was an issue
relative to
the difficulty users have in making maps
it's not obvious necessarily how these
districts go together so i thought well
you know it's it's sort of a
um
as you can see it's kind of a
mathematical
sort of uh
process you have to go through and so
computers are good at that
they're good at doing iterations
and so this is basically
a uh
other software
that you're seeing right now another
piece of software that um does these
iterations on finding all the possible
maps
so it's not so it's
for me
i mean from the you know the software i
okay joel did you have anything else
before we go to the thumbnails
um i'm just going to click on one of
these just to show you how the map works
okay i just um
there are just a look at the table
really quickly it shows a few stats
relative to each one of the maps it's
mean deviation it's deviation range
constituents per seat
total seats few or were shorted
district total seat total and you can
sort these
okay
all right so so there's the table there
um and so i'm just gonna i'm gonna sort
it by um deviation range just
maybe you care about deviation ranges
you know maybe that's a big thing and
you want one but the smallest deviation
range
and so this
it's sorted now that that one at the top
has the lowest deviation range i click
on it
and it's filled in the map
so you can you can take a look at that
map
um
i thought i i oh i need a resha i got i
there we go
and so so here's a map you can take a
look at it see what you think i'll just
show you one other thing that i can do
um there's a button up here to reset map
so i'm gonna get rid of that map okay so
it just clears it out and i can say
um you know i maybe you're somebody who
lives in new london you just say
i wanna i want
my
uh new london to be on its own okay but
i don't care about the rest of the
county so show me a map
that that does that or show me maps that
do that
and um
so you click on solutions
and so this is a smaller table but all
of these will
will be ones where new london has its
own district
oh
i do this long enough i'll
so um
these there's still quite a few of them
here so i'm just going to click on one
and
there we go there's a map
you could have sorted that other table
if you wanted to based on whatever your
criteria is
okay all right
so so there you go and there you see
that new london is its own district
so
i have no idea you'd have to take a look
at this map see if you like it you can
also not do just one
district you could complete it as much
as you want
hit the solutions button and it'll show
you any maps that it may have in the
database
may not show you anything maybe there's
nothing who knows maybe you
got yourself into a corner or whatever
could happen or or or it's kind of
yeah so but there's no promise that this
this will have every possible map in it
okay it's just an aid you can ignore it
if you want
it depends on you
um and then
the last thing would be
you want me to
uh just so you know you can kind of work
on counties county by county so like i
could
um i'm going to just save this one
so so that's saved also and then you can
save once you get all your counties done
or maybe two counties whatever you want
then you can save the whole plan
this one apparently i called nothing
much i was just playing around
and so this is nothing much
um and i'll i'll save that one
um
and um so now we have both
uh merrimack saved and also what we were
working on um
sullivan so sullivan is saved too so if
i come back in i can open up both of
those by opening the plan and they'll
both pop up
so you can work on both the county level
or the whole state level
so that is basically i think what i have
to
show i guess um so we could move on to
and uh that software always gives you
prompts whether you want to save a plan
before you
to you know accidentally
okay so
the um
on your your
thumb drive
what i'm going to show you also
well i guess
i'm running over
well we need to go through this joel so
you get the floor okay all right
um i just wanted to show you also
um how you can go about
um deleting the program from from your
computer
why don't we why don't we get into the
installation first time okay
let's do that first um
i don't want to put the focus at the
first on deletion and if um
yeah i just wonder if somebody's paying
attention i don't know are you a do you
expect that we're looking at something
on the screen or not because i'm not
so sharing screen needs to happen again
somehow
yeah we're back to the original screen
setup whenever you closed out that
program we lost what was
the connection i think to your screen
okay
all right there we go
so you're are you just seeing the the
whiteboard right now just whiteboard
okay
um
i wanted to
show the
show the laptop here made my uh
hopefully
you just need a more talented operator
here that's all
i think from this demonstration it's
pretty clear that we're going to have to
play around with the software
and make
multiple tries at maps before we can
decide that anything is
is good enough to present to our public
because
obviously there's going to be more than
okay so
joel why don't we go through we have
some drives what kind of computer system
do we need
to
install it
actually you know
um
you need a windows computer
so that's that's the the
way it works now
uh that's not to say
and i don't know what the plans are i
have a windows computer and so that the
um
the packaging tool that i have
it makes it so that it creates a an
installation file for whatever computer
that you use
to to create it the um
the installation file so the
installation file is made for windows
computers okay at this point
my understanding is if
if i did that on an apple computer and
that that
installation file would work on an apple
computer i haven't done that or a linux
computer say
okay and when we install it and go ask
our computer to open this drive what are
uh you're going to see what's going to
happen is um
when you put your thumb driving in your
computer you're gonna see um
i think you'll see three files on there
one file will be labeled um
read first
license agreement
so you should read that first
and then that controls the the software
and in terms of use of that software
and then the two other files
uh one will be
the house redistricting file and it'll
just be a file that is is executable
so all you do is
you click on it double click on it
and it'll pop up
and it's a
it's an installer and it's a windows
installer basically and it will install
the program on your computer
and it will put a um
a shortcut on your desktop
and then then to run the program what
you need to do is um
just click click on that icon and the
program will come up
so it's very simple
type of installation you don't even have
to answer any questions
or whatever it's an automatic install
that's the way it works and you said
there were three files
yes and the third file is for
um doing congressional districts
so it's the it's basically the same
software
um but it's it's uh
it has there's a switch in there that
you can turn it on so it does statewide
so that statewide switch has been turned
on
and um it's um
the deviation will be calculated based
on two districts for the congressional
one because there are only two seats per
congressional district so as you and all
you'll be doing with that software is
creating two large districts
so if you i don't know who's doing that
i was just asked to put that together um
and so it'll give you a deviation at the
end you know with the
district label
you shouldn't use a floaterial function
with that because of the fact
that uh well you don't have so materials
and uh you know in congressional
districts and
um it but it it i was gonna try to turn
that off but it was gonna take a lot of
playing with
the guts of the computer and
didn't want to do that or didn't have
the time to do that all right so i think
we're all set on what you're going to
see when you put it in your computer
um is there a separate one for the
executive counselors
not as young
um
you know it would be the same thing
as the congressional one
um except
just need to change the number of seats
so i
going to show my ignorance here how many
executive consular seats are there in
this state the software that we have um
in the house
retain the services of joel
for deal with what he just spoke of
as he said there is an end license end
user license agreement please read it
um normally we would have you have to
click that before you get to the program
but because we wanted you to get this
information today
um it is separate so i am asking you to
please read it because this is a
legislative work product as joel
explained this was something that he
worked on 10 years ago and over the past
10 years and it's the intellectual
property of the general court
in regards to the maps themselves you
you know that this committee has six
bills we had a public hearing on it
and retained the six bills um
and the senate as of this time of course
has their own rules and hasn't done
bills but i can tell you that
historically the senate has been given
the opportunity to work on
their district lines for its own body as
has this body
and i expect that going forward under my
chairmanship we are going to honor that
historical agreement where they will be
working on their senate lines right off
the executive council
and we will of course that will be
subject to our review but that will be
in their
purview in the first instance as the
house districts which you have just seen
um the software for
will be in our
um
just in our purview i i am also
expecting that
the senate will be taking on the in the
first instance the proposals for
the executive council
that is my expectation as we all know
the senate runs on its own timeline and
we sort of
wait to see what happens but that's the
expectation
and that that means that our initial
focus will be on my expectation is and
that's how we're going forward is the
house
and the congressional districts
there are also obviously two other bills
in regards to the county commissioners
and the state party
delegates which is sort of a little
nuanced one but
that in the first instance is how i
expect this work to be going forward um
as you can see you're going to have
plenty of you're going to need plenty of
time to play with the maps for the house
districts
it's not quite as straight forward as
people
seem to think it is especially due to
the size of our districts and
representation is very unusual
and it makes it frankly probably the
most complicated mathematically task
that we have in front of us so
we're going to be getting that and
is there anything on the disk right now
that is not accurate or we shouldn't
rely on
um
no i think everything on the disk
to the best of my knowledge is accurate
you know the census data is in there
the new numbers i feel confident about
those numbers
um the main problem i was having with
the four counties
there is no
map database for them
so you know that solutions i i showed
you before
that does not work
um
so colossus grafton rockingham and
stratford
those four um and that was just because
um
takes a
part of it is
it would take some computing
power or time to run some of those
um
and
in one of the counties
uh stratfor there's some blog in this
software that i'm not quite sure where
it came from so basically
um
so what you have
you'll be able to do mapping your basic
mapping for all the counties but when if
you try to do the solutions
on coast graft and rockingham and
stratford
um you won't get anything
all right
just to repeat what joel said so that's
clear on
the solutions button which is which is
sort of unique does not work for coast
rockingham stratford and grafton you can
still click on the county you still do
your maps you just don't have the
benefit of the programming to do
one
possible solution for those
so when you click on it and you don't
get anything it's not that your
data is not working it's not there
and frankly you know given i'm more
concerned i as chair more concerned with
making sure this census data is accurate
was tied to the communities and then my
focus will be on updating having him
update for the ward information as it
comes in
so we can do that in any other updates
but um the solutions was a nice
thing but
it's not critical to us getting our work
done and so i wanted you to get
the data and the thumb drive today
so follow up on the other question i
asked i understand the senate will take
the first stab at the congressional
executive council on the other seats
will we have the tools to double
checking for the fund
at that time i don't know
because the senate has not made
definitive plans at this point and at
this point this is what we have with
joel
madame chairman i think representatives
the senate my understanding is
not used to the congressional district
representative lane my understanding
from what madam chairman chambers said
is that we will start with a current
expectation
correct representative lane wants a
program to redo what the senate does and
at this point the senate has not made
okay
thanks
when you don't know if you're not clear
you never know when you're clarified so
all right anything else on the
programming representative william
uh i thank you madam chair i have two
questions the first uh i'm curious if uh
data on race from the 2020 census
uh is built into this software at all to
be in compliance with the voting rights
act
no there's no erased data in there
okay
uh thank you and the the other question
you know it's a it's about your
continued involvement in this and really
grateful for your service to the general
court control i'm curious if you will be
a resource
uh to the committee
uh as a nonpartisan you know expert in
this uh to help us draw our events
yeah i'm most happy to talk with any
member of the committee you know if you
have any questions about the software
um
i'm not going to help you make a map
at all but in terms of being
non-partisan
um i worked for the house community
research office for 30 some years and
that was our role there and i i didn't
yeah other questions
thanks
on the install you put the thumb drive
in i wanted to get a little more
granular is it a better practice to copy
um works both ways i tried it both ways
i think you can do it straight from the
thumb drive
okay
it'll install the files on your computer
so
anything else on the on the programming
so joel joel has been retained
um
by the the speaker's office
in order to provide this service since
he is no longer
employed by the general court as a
full-time employee
and uh in regards to getting it i think
um i will be se i will send out an email
to committee members with specifics as
to how to contact joel in regards to
questions when they come up come up
um because uh i probably email is going
to be we'll have to have email and phone
in the process of relocating and having
some exciting things going on so
we want to make sure we don't abuse him
either in regards to what time
commitments he has made um and we'll get
something firmed up for you
trying to
um
get done with this before lunch so if
anybody has any questions and and wants
to actually um see the map on you on
your computer i want everybody to
understand it's got 2010 data joe will
not be working on maps with 2020 he's
maintaining a non-partisan position and
not getting involved
and i'm not sure who wanted that more
all right so what if you could why don't
you stay and
and then after after the meeting if
committee members want to talk to you
they can
all right thank you
all right um going back to our agenda we
had talked in our meeting
in june hard to believe it was almost
two months ago now
um adoption of standards for for mapping
because part of what's going to happen
in this process are
public listening sessions in the various
counties
i have decided that it would be helpful
when we go to those county listening
sessions if it's very clear to people
participating in those sessions that
they understand
what our parameters are as as you just
saw this is very much a math exercise
and the most basic component of it is
the census data we are required to use
the census data i will tell you um it is
my preference that we make that clear
because
i understand but that there are
different jurisdictions that are
considering whether or not they are
going to proceed with the census data
without litigation
because of some adjustments that the
census did to the data
i
there is no
basis from what i can tell for new
hampshire to do that we have been told
representative smith and i i had the
opportunity along with representative
wilhelm to to attend a national
conference when the census data was
presented um excuse me people from the
census data were there um
in regards to the fact that the numbers
that were being presented were the
numbers we were going to be using um and
there is no leeway i don't believe in
our constitution or our work to to do
that so
it would be my preference that this
committee adopt by motion that the 2020
census data numbers will in fact be
those used for our work proceeding
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair i do make a motion that the new
hampshire house special committee
on redistricting utilizes the population
numbers provided in the 2021 u.s census
data
that's been moved and seconded is there
not seeing any i'm going to ask the
yes
yeah
look at that
all right
um in regards to the specific tasks that
we need to do i think as we've all
realized this morning that the house is
certainly of direct interest and one of
the more
difficult
tasks to undertake
in our previous meeting we discussed
the requirements in the constitution and
in law and we've discussed that a little
this morning
is there a motion in regards to what
there should be the basic math criteria
district representative mcguire yes i
move that we
make the house district such that county
lines are not frost
and we follow the constitutional
requirements that they be contiguous and
vary from
and did that include city and
unincorporated places also
unincorporated places yes if we don't
reach ward lines we won't be reaching
city lines thank you um i will and thank
you for that clarification there are
some cities who have finally thrown up
their hands in regards to warts and made
it toward the city line so i'm not sure
forward what they're going to be using
so we'll we'll see representative
bergeron will tell us a little more
about that is there any further
discussion on the motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
that's better
representative steve smith
yes
representative mcguire yes
representative
mcdonald votes yes
representative kennedy yes
representative barry yes
representative o'hara yes
representative sherbert
representative marjorie smith yes
representative bergeron
representative lane
representative
representative porter yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative griffin yes
again thank you representative mcdonald
thank you members
um i think that the groundwork is laid
now for us to do our own mapping and to
get going into the
counties throughout the state to
have our listening meetings with persons
to find out what they want to hear and i
hope people have been able to see on
youtube i understand the youtube
streaming was working
or at least hear that we have been
getting your emails and letters in
regards to
wanting your own representative if you
have enough people in your community we
have so the public is aware we have been
provided by staff
a number of communications that have
been received from the public over the
past
weeks in regards to positions that we
should take so we have those in hand
and we will be considering all of that
as we go forward before i talk about
those listening sessions
representative bergeron has agreed to
update us on what's happening with the
cities
and
how they are proceeding and you should
going around passing it out now
i'm trying to convince representative
bergeron that he does not have to do the
printing
at his own home that we can do it
at the staff here but we wanted to make
sure it got done so thank you
may i begin yes representative thank you
thank you pretty much while those sheets
are going around i
and i have mentioned this in the
previous meeting but since we have some
replacements present i want to repeat it
um census tracts are supposed to fall
within or fall along voting district
boundaries
and that happens of course in our towns
because the town lines are the voting
district boundaries
sometimes however
the census makes mistakes and they the
census tracts do not necessarily follow
ward boundaries
so the data that you have uh that's been
uploaded from the census is probably
correct in 99 of the entrance
in instances
uh but we may have to keep our ears to
the ground to see what's happening in
the cities as they start overlaying the
census data with their own um ward lines
on gis and the example i gave previously
is what occurred in nashua about 10
years ago where the census treated the
eastern boundary of one of our wards as
route 3
which is a major road north south in
southern new hampshire with uh
where the actual war boundary was the
daniel webster highway a little to the
east
which is the the mall district of the
city and in between about 1100 people
resided so that meant according to the
census there were 1100 people less than
one ward and 1100 people more in the
other and so we had to uh to make some
adjustments to the census data by moving
population blocks from one word to the
other
nations so just something to keep in
mind that something like this manchester
but not to that degree and it may occur
in other cities as well
as for the the table that i distributed
um
i think we optimistically hoped that the
cities would all complete redistricting
and stay within perhaps a 10 range of
deviation uh during that process
uh it appears that that
may not be as simple uh as we had hoped
it would be it may not occur in all the
cities so i would like to flag a couple
of instances where we might need to keep
in mind that this is not occurring or
may not occur in time for our
redistricting work the first is the city
of franklin
the city of franklin sent a letter to
the committee asking that it be treated
as a single legislative district
when i looked at the city charter online
there are footnotes whenever a charter
is amended uh on the caught a fire's
website
and the last time ward lines were
amended in franklin was 1995.
so
we also have a statement from them
indicating that they do not expect to
have the redistricting done prior to the
time this committee's work is done
so we may have to uh consider treating
franklin as its city as a city-wide uh
district as part of any flow materials
that occur
the another one to be concerned about is
claremont
i had been told by the city clerk that
claremont did not redistrict in 2011
and the reason they did not do so is in
part because their legal counsel had
advised them since they had nine
counselors three of whom were elected
one of each in each of three wards and
the other six at large that they didn't
need to uh redistrict because the
majority of their council was elected at
large based on joel's demonstration it
may also be true that uh the actual
census numbers fell within that 10 range
of deviation anyway and perhaps there
was no reason for them to redistrict but
at the present time they don't have any
uh committee appointed they don't have a
plan yet to conduct any redistricting in
claremont so i don't know what the
actual numbers and the awards for
claremont
will be or if they'll have anything done
prior to our work being completed
the third one
uh
i wanted to flag a summit's worth
somersworth process uh for
redoing the award lines is done by
referendum a committee has to be
appointed consisting of several council
members they need to come to agreement
with the new ward lines would be and
then it has to be sent to the voters
at quote the next election that's
unclear whether it's a special election
or a regular election i would assume a
special election could be held but uh we
should assume nothing
and right now no committee has yet been
appointed in summer's work so we don't
know what their what their plans are
uh the cities of dover and keene are
trying to amend their
charters
at the november election to allow them
to make changes to ward lines by
ordinance that would expedite the
process if they can get these questions
approved by the voters
the big concern with both cities is the
timeline between now and the date when
absentee ballots have to be ready for
the november election
after there's been a public hearing on
the new ward lines or on the new charter
amendment that has to be submitted to
the department of revenue administration
the secretary of state's office and the
attorney general's office for approval
and usually they have up to 60 days to
either approve or reject the request to
amend the amendment
amend the charter so uh it's going to be
critical that those three state agencies
react quickly to the requests of these
two cities
and approve that charter amendment so
they can get it on the ballot
the other cities have pretty much laid
out their plans uh portsmouth has to do
it by change to state law
we need to still talk to the portsmouth
officials to find out how that's going
to happen
during our last meeting the chair had
submitted a copy to us of
the portsmouth award lines that was done
as a session law in 2012
and so they need to
i assume they're going to need to file a
bill uh requesting that the ward lines
be changed
or it's going to have to be an amendment
to one of our
redistricting bills to make sure that
it's done it's our bill it's our bill
okay
one way or the other portsmouth needs to
get to work and define those ward lines
and we need to make sure that it becomes
part of the state law
and with that i guess i could answer to
try to answer any questions people might
have but i think i highlighted the
those areas of concern or interests that
i thought the committee like might like
so so we know the timeline is going to
we need to proceed regardless
our goal
remains to report out november 18th
we do know of course that this is the
end of the bill review process it needs
to go to our full body and to the senate
so to the extent
certain things might be figured out
after that point in time there is an
amendment process under rules in both
houses
but obviously the preference would be
not to have to do that
so
to the extent we're going to be able to
figure that out
the better and i want to thank
representative bergeron and
representative lane is helping him out
on doing this work questions for
i'm not seeing it
thank you
um the review i have put on the review
of county listening session locations
and i have this on here because
lindsay and i have begun calling the
places that were used 10 years ago
and i want to get some committee input
in regards to locations
as to their their feasibility you will
note that a number of the locations that
were used last time were nursing homes
um i'm going to assume in the first
instance that nursing homes are not
going to be available for public
meetings
um so that means that even if all of
these are still available and some were
not available to be booked until the
actual calendar month of september which
is why you don't have a schedule in
front of you i want to go through each
county and i'm going to open it up to
representatives to see if they have any
suggestions for other locations
representative smith um i have a
threshold question uh madam chair can
you tell me the difference between a
public hearing
where we receive
information from the public um
i'm just
working from the bills that we have
already
filed and a listening session
um my view and you can see i apparently
have a different view than they had ten
years ago is that public hearings are a
legislative process associated with a
specific bill
for which we open
hearing
i do not intend to conduct these opening
up a public hearing on
specific bills we can do it that way
we've already had that public hearing
when we retained the bills
so i'm just referring these to these as
a listening session additionally i want
to make it clear that it is not
necessary for the full committee to be
at these historically because they are
around the state what happens is at
least i think it was five members
of the committee attended and one person
would be designated the chair for that
session
and
someone else would be there to serve as
a clerk or to help us get the feedback
from people at the session so i'm i have
simply phrased it that way because i'm
not going to conduct it as an open
closed
public hearing represent follow-up
thank you um
as a hearing
there is no
obligation for us to have a full form
i'm aware it's only when it's an
executive session and the last thing
we're going to be doing is voting
but in terms of public perception
it seems to me that
we want to be clear to the public
that we take
what they say seriously we're listening
carefully
and the usual nomenclature would be a
hearing a listening session
is somewhat less
specific and i would hope you would
consider that and suggest referring to
these as public hearings thank you
although we know we're always listening
representative
all right thank you for that
clarification i i in no way intended to
create a record that indicated we
weren't doing exactly the same thing
representative
thank you madam chair
uh
do we intend to have any public hearings
uh after maps are drawn i understand
these listening
objects public listening sessions
uh
to be before maps are drawn
will there be an opportunity for the
public to review maps and share their
feedback
after the mastercard yes
no
we have created a website that will
allow comment to be submitted to the
committee along with maps to be uploaded
so that people can
provide maps
part of the
the remote
access to public meetings is
also due to our geography
and technical limitations there are some
portions of the state we're providing
that really is not providing anything
and it's not clear to me where we're
going to be providing these service
providing these services given what i
see as more limitations on locations to
have these
feed on a dead horse but most of these i
know in merrimack if we have it most of
the county
my understanding the county commission
hearings are available
so if we use those facilities we should
be able to
well again there is a difference between
live streaming and access so i'm not
sure what you're talking about in
regards to that because it is not the
intent to
take comment remotely certainly but
there is nothing that would prevent
anybody from
filming what is a public meeting and i
know that all counties do not have that
because i know that in hillsborough i
contacted the hillsborough county
in regards to whether or not we would be
able to use their room and there are
there are no such um capabilities their
county commissioners are actually
meeting tomorrow and they're going to
take up the request representative lane
we'll look into it but it's not clear to
me that i think that going down
um a path where we're providing
different services in different counties
makes sense i don't know
um frankly i'd like to get the locations
in a calendar set up um before we deal
with that because i think we have a
timeline and again uh there was work
done
to make sure that we had a website that
was accessible with the ability of the
public to make comment
and upload maps for our consideration
and i know all of us will be reviewing
all those maps and we're making sure
that staff make sure that we have in
hand the comments that we
are receiving so it's part of the public
record
representative
thank you madam chair um i hate to go
back on to the uh distribution of the
thumb drives but just so i'm clear and i
think everybody else is crystal clear
regarding the end user license agreement
the fact that they're in that agreement
there's no place for signatures or
anything like that is it is it uh mike
understanding that the fact that we
utilize that software we are agreeing to
the end user license agreement yes
all right thank you for those comments
everyone all right belknap do we have
anybody here who's from belknap county
you're familiar with it
representative o'hara so apparently they
used belknap mill
last time is is that uh
yeah i think that'd be the best place
it's the most open area there's no zoom
option there that's the most open for
getting those people in
okay
um
carol is
that was a nursing home
i am not even going to waste the phone
call to the carroll county nursing home
actually i think lindsay did well
does anybody know of any space in
carroll
county that might be appropriate
representative
that's a proud staff along with camp
calumet on my gossipy uh they've got
some really great facilities there and
uh
i'm sure they'd be excited to host a
civic
uh
listening
session public listening session such as
this
all right well
i i hate to do this because now this is
warning to all of you given
your respective knowledge of these
locations representative o'hara and
representative ohan would you mind
calling
them and sending me an email as to what
you might find out as to their
availability for a meeting it would be
my pleasure madam sure thank you
we want to do these since and i would
like to get these done by mid-october
and i would prefer that they be tuesday
and the other thing that you need to be
aware of is some of these places are
going to have a fee
and they will have
um insurance requirements some of them
and i have been in contact with the
speaker's office in regards to trying to
figure out what we have for a budget and
insurance and it's my understanding we
can deal with the insurance piece
and there is a small budget hopefully
people will see this uh organizations
will see this as
a civic event and
be forgiving on our fee
cheshire county
anybody here familiar with cheshire
county there's the keene public library
is that
a pretty good place
the um the library is a great room and
the parking is non-existent so i'm
i was going to suggest that
representative weber
president of cheshire county my favorite
person
uh
i i agree with representative porter
could we look at uh saint anselm's
institute of politics is actually in
your town madam chairman goss town is
it's a long drive to nashville if you
thank you um as we make these calls i
would just remind people to ask about
the accessibility of the places to make
sure that they are
merrimack was in the merrimack county
admin building i'm not sure
representative mcguire yes that room is
still available but the county
delegation has been meeting in one of
the
for one of the
rooms in the old courthouse which is now
available and i can check with the
county commissioners if you could
if you could do that
my recollection from being in the
courtroom for work is that the old
county courthouse is not that friendly
for access and representative lane
appears to be agreeing with me
um there is actually an elevator that
the last time my recollection of that
elevator is that it would be over by the
i never took that elevator i just went
right for the stairs which were
beautiful which are a beautiful
staircase but
that elevator was severely lacking and i
can't imagine they updated it given that
they just built a new building
um
rockingham
this was at the nursing home i'm not
sure what other facilities are available
on the county compound there
anybody know anything about rockingham
all right i believe um what about the
um pinkerton academy they have a very
nice spread out auditorium
uh i believe it's the performing
which is the name of the performing arts
center there's a special name for
stockbridge stockbridge
all right um
we'll we'll look there i think is
pinkerton more central
the rockingham county complex is not
that easy to get i mean it's roadwise
it's okay but it's sort of in the middle
of nowhere yeah i mean it's it's
rockingham's population split between
east and west so you're kind of damned
if you do it in if you don't okay
um stratford now the stratfor superior
court is definitely out in the middle of
nowhere um representative turcotte
i can make the contact on that one and
uh arrange the time i'm sure that will
be available
all right is there anything else in
stratford that's available that is a
to i don't think so
i mean it's an ideal spot we use it for
uh okay great access i i know it's a
little kind of down there's a couple
little turns you have to make sure you
get there that are a little tricky
they'll give us one of their
will get everybody there and it really
is the most central
place and if you get confused you'll end
up either at the jail or the nursing
home so there's no problem all right
okay
and then sullivan
yep sugar river um valley technical
center has two potential spots we could
use both are decent sized rooms lots of
parking to tell me which weeks like
and it's a tuesday or thursday i can
okay
all right so
what i'd like to happen over the next
week is that we try to firm this
the locations and the schedule
up
as soon as anything is established we
and once there they are established
we will need committee members to
essentially sign up representative
bergeron i'm sorry i went to my left and
i didn't come back to you i apologize to
you uh that's all right madam chair i
actually agree with uh representative
porter that a more central location
hillsborough county actually makes sense
coming from nashua thank you very much
this way i don't have to make a phone
call
representative lane
thank you just for clarification are we
asking them for one day or for two so
the one
not for the one after
the maps are drawn no because
we haven't decided how we're doing it
after the maps are drawn this is
this is very focused on accounting
representative turcotte and just for
clarification the dates that you put
down here are not set in stone whatever
kind of no no these are dates from 10
years ago there are no dates oh so it's
just tuesday we've got you gotcha you
know like they might be there might be a
use of the it every thursday night so we
can only use that place tuesday or
wednesday um hold on to that
representative
when do you anticipate uh a plan for
post map hearings
i do not
i have no anticipation at this time for
post-math
events
but we will have
there will be some sort of a public
representative smith asked when
um
would like this to begin
and given the start of school and labor
day being the sixth
um the
earliest week that i would think that
this could begin would be the week of
correct
i have no opinion on uh as to that
because i
think that if the earlier it is the the
more we will begin examining maps in
public um given the november deadline i
think it would be nice for us to be to
start talking about maps actual maps
here certainly a month before that right
um so that puts us to mid october which
means we really sort of want to get
these loaded into september in the first
and as we noted the november 18th date
is what we are shooting for there is the
ability to request the body of the house
to waive the rules to report out later
but
i can barely control a committee of 15 i
think i'd rather just be able to go
without trying to ask for a waiver of
exactly let it be noted that today there
was a meeting of the
special committee on redistricting in
the house of representatives and we were
unanimous
that is all i had on my agenda for
business today
um you will be getting emails in regards
to where we stand on scheduling they
will be posted on the website um the
next meeting of this committee will be
at the call of the chair after
um we have gone through this
joel is available he's still here um if
you want to talk to him directly about
the maps and and try a few clicks
yourself if he allows people to use his
computer you can at least ask him to do
that again joel is here as a part-time
employee
retained by the speaker's office in the
general court he is non-partisan and he
will not be doing maps for you
representative barry did you have your
any other questions
all in favor
sometimes it's nice to just do those
votes without having to do the roll call
isn't it yes
all right
thank you everybody for coming